-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Adam Scott.
So, "Severance," which, I mean,
we've been singing the praises
of "Severance" on this show
for a while.
-Really nice. I know you have.
It's really cool.
-But this is a very high-concept
show about people who can have
a chip put in their brains
that will basically
separate their work persona
with their home persona.
-That's right.
It separates your memory.
So when you're at work,
you have no idea who you are
in the outside world, and then
when you cross the threshold
of work to go home, the chip
is deactivated so you have
no memory of who you are at work
or anything you do there,
so you're leading
two completely separate lives.
-So it's this very high-concept
sort of sci-fi idea.
It is very stylized
in the shooting.
It's a fantastic cast, but I
imagine in the making of it,
are you constantly wondering,
"Are people going to get this?"
-Oh, yeah. I mean, the whole
time we were making it,
we were like,
"This is so weird."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No clue whatsoever if anyone --
Like, what are people going to
do with this?
You know, and actually when it
started -- Like in January when
the billboards went up in town,
the billboards were just,
like, my head, right?
And I started freaking out.
February 18th,
when the show was coming out,
it was like this locomotive
headed towards me.
And I started freaking out
and calling Ben Stiller,
who's the executive producer,
directed a bunch of it,
just with these neurotic,
nitpicky calls like,
"I don't know if the thing
in episode three is
properly setting up the thing
in episode five.
What do you think?"
He's like,
"Yeah, no, everything is okay."
And it's like, okay, alright.
And then I would have
some other reason.
Eventually after a few of
these calls, I was just like,
"Ben, I think what it comes down
to is I just don't want people
to think I suck."
[ Laughter ]
And he's like, "Okay, alright.
I don't think people are
going to think you suck."
But he'd kind of been through
the thing of his head
being up on the side
of a building before,
so he was like, "Anytime
you're freaking out, call me.
It's all good."
And he was like really great
with all that.
-He did an incredible job.
It's beautifully written.
You know, again, it's so
stylized, and it takes place --
Most of it takes place
in this very sort of
sterile office environment.
It seems incredibly
claustrophobic.
Was it claustrophobic
in real life as well?
-Yeah, the set is strange 'cause
the carpet in our office is
bright green, the ceiling is
quite low.
So, yeah, after nine months of
shooting in this environment,
we all were starting to go
a little crazy.
-And on your computer screens,
the sort of menial work you do
is just clicking on numbers
as they start to,
I guess, throb would maybe be --
-Sure?
-That's, like -- That's my
kind of go-to word.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Like, when all else fails,
just go to "throb"?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Just don't do that
while texting.
-Obviously!
[ Laughter ]
-Teenagers.
-But they ask for my number!
-I get it.
-But what are you actually
doing on the screen?
-We are actually going around
and eliminating numbers, like,
exactly like what we're doing.
They designed
the exact computer program
that you see on the show.
-Because, you know, you
mentioned "The Office" earlier.
On that show, people were always
doing different things
on their computer.
But this was you actually had to
do the number game?
-Yeah. On "Parks & Rec,"
I remember they had Internet
access on all those computers
that people were at
in the background,
so you could just, like,
browse the Internet on camera.
But on this, we were actually
eliminating numbers.
Like Zach Cherry, who's in the
show, got really good at it.
[ Laughter ]
I was not as good.
And then the trackball they
designed for the specific
computer is ergonomically
impossible, so we all started
getting this weird
new carpal tunnel.
[ Laughter ]
-You're really giving a ringing
endorsement of show business.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This was near the end
of the season.
There was a dance party.
Here you are.
[ Laughter ]
Here are two of
your cast members.
This was sort of a very,
I feel like, if you can say
there's an iconic scene
in a new show,
but this was very much that.
What did you know
about the scene
before you started shooting it?
-Well, we knew
just what was scripted.
It ended up taking about two
days to shoot that whole scene,
and the thing that Ben had kept
from us and surprised us with
on the day was that the
fluorescent lights we had been
living with for months
and months,
once the music starts,
Tramell Tillman,
who plays Milchick,
hits a remote control
and they turn into like
disco lights
and the entire ceiling just
starts --
and we had no idea
that was going to happen.
So the reaction you see of us
kind of marveling
at these lights are actual
actors that have been trapped
in this room for nine months
being dazzled by disco lights.
-You do seem absolutely in awe.
-Yeah, yeah.
-This is such a technically
precise show.
I feel like you watch it and it
seems as though the actors
have this incredible freedom
because you're all so good,
but I imagine there is something
a little bit more rigid
when you have to be in a show
where -- I mean, everything is
so beautifully framed,
so perfectly shot.
-Yeah. Kind of the second
I walked onto the set I thought,
oh, okay, I've never really done
something like this before.
This is going to be all about
technical precision but also
being able to figure out
the acting in and out and around
that technical precision, which
I had never really done before.
So I just -- Knowing that I
trusted Ben as much as I do,
I just decided to give myself
over to the technical needs of
the show and to completely lean
on him
for all of the acting stuff
because I wasn't going to be
able to keep an eye on it myself
'cause I had too much to do,
I guess.
-It looks like whatever you guys
had to put into it, it paid off.
It couldn't have paid off better
in the show itself.
-Oh, thanks.
-It's wonderful.
I can't wait for more. Thank you
so much for being here.
-Thanks, Seth.
-Adam Scott, everybody.
"Severance" is streaming on
Apple TV+.